[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember so you don't have to you might
be wondering why I asked you to stay
after in this classroom scenario I
suddenly decided to make up
well it's your show intros they're
appalling look at how standard short and
run-of-the-mill they are these are the
openings to your show you can't have
them be this ordinary this will not do
it all your assignment is to find better
nostalgic openings for me to review the
intro is one of the most important parts
of any show it establishes the tone
style and even story of what you're
about to see so you and I are gonna look
over some of the most memorable ones to
see if they work or not
I expect this assignment on my desk the
very next day it is now the very next
day I sit very still what do you have
for me let's go over this together shall
we
[Music]
ah the 80s fantasy that asks the
question I'm straight right if I like
he-man that that still makes me straight
right what if I like she Rob that makes
me gay how many stereotypes make any
sense whatever your preference he-man
needed an intro to get you invested fast
they did a pretty good job of it just
look at the first epic thing you saw
after that yeah now that's an epic shit
right there although I always wanted to
ask this am I the only one that feels
like the narrator sounds like dr.
Zoidberg the Masters of the Universe
wine art it starts off with Adam
introducing himself and his battle cat
Cringer Prince of Eternia and defender
of the secrets of Castle Grayskull a -
runjesus
fabulous secret powers were revealed to
me the day I held aloft my magic sword
and said by the power
we don't really explain why I did or
said that I was just going through my
holding aloft my magic sword and saying
by the power of Grayskull face it just
happened to contain fabulous secret
powers suddenly I became more naked and
people thought that was a different
person time to blow up this damn cat oh
hi it does that apparently that's cool
and I became he-man not sure why he
punched the person he was telling the
story to I became he-man what you call
my mother die asshole boy Lucian is
credit kind of kills the buzz doesn't it
let's take this time kids to acknowledge
you executive produce this show let's
also take time kids to acknowledge the
production director all right here's
some more bullshit together we defend
Castle Grayskull from the evil forces of
Skeletor
in hindsight he probably should live
there it does look like his face is
plastered all over it he actually lives
in castle rather bar we should probably
trade he men eventually got a popular
spin-off called sneer earth I mean Shira
with a very similar introduction I am
stoned out of my mind which is why I'm
still uncomfortably close to you the day
I held aloft my America power I got
honor it's kind of a consolation prize
actually I have an established shoe
he-man is what Grayskull is why I have
the honor of it or the connection it has
to the kingdom I just said I was from
but I have a god damn unicorn holy shit
yeah how many battle cats do you see a
merchandise everywhere nowhere I don't
see a battle cat I got a unicorn bitch
eh I've got a unicorn on top of that I
got Top Billing he-man has to share his
title with the Masters of the Universe I
had to share my title with more me
that's me co-starring me even Liu Shama
doesn't get credit until the end keep
your power and your misc acid off longer
and I got the real honour here why did I
make her pretty we even have rainbow
colored characters because we're not
afraid to hide our pride over here
you're so deep in the closet you're tap
dancing with our Kelly overall these are
kind of vague and weird but they still
managed to have a silly epic feel to
them I'm giving these intros an 85
now is time for cake
hey Paesanos it's the Super Mario
Brothers Super Show it's pretty sad when
he had to say this is a better
interpretation of Mario Brothers than
the Mario Brothers movie especially when
it opens with a Mario rap ah yeah we let
this happen the fight thing is both this
and the movie opened up with the exact
same Mario music to make you think
you're gonna see something decent oh
good this is gonna be something great
with the Mario Brothers immediately lost
we can practically see the look in
Mario's eyes when the rap starts as if
to say it's this kind of show gotta love
that choreography to everyone do the
drunk uncles shuffling to the next bar
step get used to those flag poles we'll
never see on the show here's another
line I never understand did he say tell
the French we got to get those European
ratings up if they find this funny
they'll find us funny too the French
croppings a little off guys though I
mean it's a warp zones this indication
from public-access luigi doesn't even
have the energy to run all the way he
stops just before the end as if to say
the cash is checked right I can't read
me again this Mario actually had two
other spin-offs with slightly different
openings one was Super Mario Brothers 3
it is a legend no one will forget yes
they'll remember it so much they'll
forget there was never a second one and
I know what you're thinking that one
didn't count because it was a dream but
you know what we're putting a three at
the end of this one so where to go where
to go and why are we numbering our
legends this is really weird
that's right he found someone to bang
him I won't name names but Fiona was on
the rebound after Shrek four and royal
child support does pay well music
applause the Super Mario Brothers
rescued Princess Toadstool
and beat back
spoilers yeah they just kind of give
away how every episode ends not they'll
try to stop them but they did stop them
this is the Mario Brothers rescued
bridges toadstools I read the script and
I don't care anything with the Mario
name on it you'll think is great yeah I
cut to that on purpose fight me dick
holes they also had another spin-off
with Super Mario World this intro is
focused on the Italian plumbers from
Brooklyn only now they're in prehistoric
times
so naturally the music should be
Jamaican I swear Yoshi has breasts for a
second he has breasts is he going to the
same sex changes Berto or is that just
how we fed baby Mario got in my the
creative choice to belts world every
time sorry I was stuffing down a lot of
product placement some of it had to come
up we mean running away like our it's a
door being generally useless hey you
probably wouldn't do much either if your
world of mushrooms unexplainably turn
into dinosaurs cavemen and phallic
gumdrops connection
still Hemis intros are entertaining
despite them being obvious awkward game
advertisements from beginning to end I'm
giving this one a 72 this is 29 the KCI
road you can already tell this is a
British show it's great its opening
exciting words are in a dress but don't
worry they spice it up with some fruit
and this is Eric the schoolboy who leads
an amazing double life this is really
the most exciting thing you can come up
with Britain an amazing transformation
occurred he gets his daily dose of
potassium brought to you by the European
fruit Union to make bananas cool are
they cool yet or bananas cool yet
bananas are cool okay so despite this
being a very simple opening it does ask
a lot of concerning questions first of
all was he always into bananas before he
discovered this power he has a pillow
and alarm clock even a framed picture a
framed picture of a banana
hopefully you love you will that be if
he was banana man without him even
knowing it also what the hell is he
swimming through space stop that it gets
women's space you frigging buffoon this
is why your banana man even super 10 is
making fun of you
no no no no this is short ridiculous
weird I'm only giving it a 49 with a
rotten fruit sticker you better give me
something better Britain
I'm listening castle ocular home for
many centuries to a dreadful dynasty a
vicious vampire doubts what the comes of
ducking ah okay it's silly but this guy
says this dialogue like he's been
waiting all his life to explain this
mythos I think he actually believed this
is the thing this does not suffice
however for they may be brought back to
life by means of a secret range that can
be performed once essentially when the
moon is Castlevania took itself this
seriously it creates what looks like the
duck formerly known as Prince as it
takes I guess a more fitting turn as a
pop song starts going with some kind of
loopy lyrics the vampire Hall of Fame
yeah like comma yeah we were desperate
for a rhyme we didn't have very much
time working on the studio Hey duck
Euler I just love how even the main
character and the title is like I don't
know if they're smokin either folks duck
EULA I don't know it gets even more
weird in the end credits as the song is
interrupted with random clips you know
if you want to be more comically
strained you have to go with more random
clips I mean really random like you can
put anything in there it's kind of
amazing plastics my name is Inigo
Montoya you killed my father prepare to
die we come up with overall it's super
ridiculous but it's super inventive to
with a great style artwork and
balls-to-the-wall narration I'm giving
this intro a 90
don't you love Fatima's going through a
lot of shows over the years but by far
one of the most head-scratching is
spider-man and his amazing friends and
the intro certainly reflects that just
look at the first shot
whoa I'm trippin spider balls man listen
to this narration they clearly just went
with the first take spider-man and his
amazing friends the way he says it it's
like he's referring to look Susie made
spider-man brownies what an amazing
friend and these amazing friends are as
follows Iceman and Firestar that's it
two of the lesser x-men that nobody
associate with spider-man at all Iceman
and Firestar maybe they did something in
the comics I don't know you're not gonna
look it up wires face was derpy yeah
featuring them and there akia showroom
isn't helping
why are there two beds in the living
room anyway but where does Iceman sleep
is that as bed do you make that for
himself
hey you think boost banner has a picture
of spider-man at his house now that this
makes sense but that monster from the
opening a scooby-doo appears and they
turn their living room into blinking
lights the architect must have fun with
that blueprint you'll want me to do what
suck your mother shit I froze myself I
have two minutes to live
[Music]
Wow murders
whether by freezing you solid or burning
you alive you will feel the wrath of
spider-man and his merciless friends
even doctor dooms fashionable maxi dress
can't compete with the slaughtering
power of their intro okay okay if this
still has more dignity then but it still
needed a lot more updates to represent
the time period it was made I am giving
this one a 31 spider-man and his amazing
friend
my hunch hell yeah this was a great
cartoon with a great cartoon opening the
Real Ghostbusters suck a copyright
starts with the ghost in the logo
dancing down the street at first you're
wondering why you'd be afraid of him but
then oh my God he's gonna French me
you're a sex offender when you were
alive the logo flashes and Janine gets
the call alerting the guys now I'm just
gonna leave while ray was doing under
Egan's waste of mystery that is an
awfully big smile though Slimer sexually
harasses Janine and they're on their way
to stop an army of ghosts with the
incredible strategy of standing in one
spot not moving so they can be easily
blasted
I was like how the singer sounds like
he's mid orgasm whenever he says the
word call who you gonna call who you
gonna call this show sadly produced a
spin-off called Slimer and the Real
Ghostbusters which focus more on the
snack goblin leading to a more cartoony
style but still delivering a pretty
creative opening
[Music]
yeah does the Zul dog really need to be
in the same continuity as that mutant
Tiny Toon and Pizza the Hutt no it does
not
regardless these openings are still
pretty good with great animation great
speed and of course a great song I'm
giving this a 98
[Music]
okay problem number one there would
never be a Dungeons and Dragons ride now
you can experience the magic of sitting
in your basement arguing who gets laid
less I always want that argument who's
this creep by the way old to be there
isn't he maybe he's the living version
of that ghost that tries to tongue you
and the Ghostbusters intro
[Music]
[Applause]
you go um how many riders did this
happen - I mean it's a long line outside
that ride did all of them get met with
this experience it's just a warning
outside that says warning we're not
responsible if your child randomly
enters a life-destroying dimension must
be at least this hide to ride I love
this wizard who's supposed to be their
guardian but he just looks at him like
that sucks to be them just throw him in
the pile of other carnival riders that
came here see a lot Ranger he does give
him weapons which he could have used
himself but it makes sense to put small
children's lives in danger over his
pulled answers okay sure
[Music]
well he wasn't much of a villain his
first move was bad aim with a pice
blooding sound effect that was Benja the
force of evil
I am dungeon master we both hetero
parents giving us names to ruin our
lives you'll guide in the realm of
Dungeons and Dragons now let me
introduce you to our Wayans brother yeah
this isn't granting me the animation is
rush the story is dumb and I definitely
wouldn't put together this is one of the
longest-running RPGs of all time I give
this opening as 20 Dungeons & Dragons oh
[Music]
man this one's a rush I don't know if
the show was any good but the intro was
a lot of fun the song tells you
everything you need to know
[Music]
oh hell I brought up to speed the fact
these megha already make him super I
don't think that needs to be emphasized
and not only do we get to see Megaman
naked but he's damn scary naked where
the hell was that design for the
Terminator this intro is fast as hell
throwing everything at you
sparks explosions Angry Birds there
should be a death toll to this opening
how many people you think died in those
cities did she have a vacuum for an arm
maybe she's the daughter of mega maid
they both have the word mega it kinda
knew that dude on fire not only lit but
disintegrated there isn't even a grain
of Ash left finally proto man shows up
and it looks like it's gonna be a big
finish but it ends a little awkwardly
wait for all that buildup you think the
final strike would be a little bit more
epic still this intro is pretty awesome
great animation fun song get you super
hyped I'm given this intro a 95
[Music]
like sure are taking their time with the
credits on this one I hope it's building
up to something good
instantly sold instantly confused I
guess these kids find a dinosaur egg
with a live dinosaur in it so what do
they do put them in a rock band of
course that's what dr. grant would want
somehow I feel like these two species
would mix well look at the way he licks
his tongue at that couple it cuts away
just before he eats their faces I don't
really go into much detail on the
backstory in fact the whole thing just
looks like an 80s ad for dinosaur
cookies
[Music]
wait how can you be more than a friend
with a dinosaur if you're friends what's
really after oh my god they don't keep
dwelling on sex and this episode but
what else could it mean what was going
on here when he makes this face dirty
diner
[Music]
a picture is upside down yeah I can deal
with the dinosaur being an 80s band with
a bunch of kids but that picture is
upside down boom yeah that looks pretty
cool until you put neon pink denver
above it with him giving the loudest
wink should get that looked at
it's definitely a time capsule of well a
time capsule but it is bright and
colorful and for the time even has some
impressive layering effects I guess it
worked for what it is I give it a 70
[Music]
here you go one of the greatest openings
of all time for one of the greatest
shows of all time it starts off with the
Warner Brothers logo turning into a
police blimp those very practical ones
the police use all the time we see two
criminals about to rob the bank bank and
they blow it up
[Music]
you know it just hit me why did they
blow it up if they already robbed it why
draw attention if they didn't rob it the
money's up in smoke
this must be the work of a man we cut to
the Batmobile represented by a still
painted foreground against an animated
background it's usually the other way
around and he helps the police chase
down the villains get up there so fast
police were right behind them and then
suddenly they're on top of a building
what's in that Bank gummiberry juice
they of course come across the dark
night as we all ask the classic question
what is that white dot on his lip and
why doesn't it appear in later seasons
he knocks the guns out of their hands
and we come across the one bit of
animation I always thought was a little
weird he always moves like a hand puppet
there I know he's a ninja like but I'm
expecting a snake tongue to go with that
move
[Music]
he leads the criminals for the cops as
our title character is so well known the
titles not even needed for the show
though I will admit as satisfying as
that intro is don't you kinda watch him
get hit by lightning we all don't have
that you didn't this opening is so good
so artistically pleasing so musically
driven you don't even notice all the
little details I was bringing up earlier
this is one of the best-looking intros
ever and to this day there's never been
anything like it they did a few other
intros in the future but it was mostly
clips with some clever editing and
nothing on the scale of this it gets
better and better every time I see it
what can I say it's amazing this isn't
easy 100%
[Music]
I suppose that's enough for today but if
you like me to continue let me know
leave a comment below and tell me if
this is a segment you like to see more
of I'm the Nostalgia Critic and you'll
excuse me there's a certain theme month
I have to get ready for oh sorry we have
to update the calendars around here
[Music]
[Applause]
you